I'm an ecologist I work an organization
called eco health alliance we work in
wildlife conservation and human health
and do a lot of research into the
wildlife origins of human diseases and
how the interactions between humans and
animals can be improved both to protect
animals and reduce the risk of new
disease spillovers and that ranges from
field veterinary work to app development
work data science in between you know
everything you know wildlife -
whiteboards and involves a lot of
collaboration and a lot of data sharing
with many different groups doing having
different skill sets working in
different paradigms around the world I
also as Jared said worked with this
organization our open side that builds
tools to help people primarily using our
do more open and reproducible science so
we're really interested in making sure
that the research that people do gets
out into the world in a way that people
can reuse the analyses and the data that
originate in the lab and can go out into
other research groups into businesses
and so you can sort of have that
multiplicative effect of that research
do and so in both of these contexts I'm
really interested in how data gets out
and when you talk to people who are in
scientific reproducibility who are
librarians they're sort of a series of
best practices one has when you're
sharing scientific data that people want
people to adhere to you want to make
sure that data is in machine and human
readable formats so it can be future
proof your CSV ES and TSVs your XML and
Jason's all those formats they can be
parsed by lots of different languages
they probably part be able to be parsed
by future languages if people don't know
that you can open it up and inspect it
and see what the problems are that's
thought of best practice and you want to
put those in long-term scientific
library archives that have a lifespan
beyond you know the current grant cycle
the current business model people who
have figured out how to do this sort of
library level archiving to make sure
that we can have things available you
know after your project wraps up you
want standardized metadata so data can
talk to each
other so they can link to each other so
people can use that information to
understand what is in the data set
they're looking at and you need
documentation of all of that now one of
the things we do a lot in the our
community is package data into our
packages right and it's kind of funny
when you put it data into an r package
that doesn't necessarily work with this
paradigm usually the data is in the RDS
and RDA formats which are binary and not
inspectable and specific to a language
and even though our manual tells you it
could change from version to version so
it may not be future proof github and
cran which is where we put these
packages are great but they're not
necessarily built for a long-term
archiving at the scale that libraries
and scientific repositories are and when
it comes to metadata and documentation
that's possible but you may or may not
you know do that because it's not
enforced in the places that packages are
put nonetheless it is something we do a
lot so this is from a little project we
did at the ARB inside conference last
year where we were looking at how people
use our packages to transfer data and
the first thing that pops out is that we
do it a great deal almost half of the
packages on cran distribute a dataset in
some way now a lot of the times that
data set is an example data set for a
statistical method or for the for a
function that is packaged in the library
but lots of those data sets are here's
in our package for associating with a
book or in our package associated with
scientific paper or something else where
people you know want that data to get
into the hands of people but it doesn't
meet those requirements so why do we do
it well there's a bunch of advantages of
having a data in the package and the
first is you get to hijack the package
distribution and storage infrastructure
cran and github the places we host
package are very central very visible a
lot less fragmented than actually the
scientific data repository world and so
you have a lot of visibility by putting
something up there secondarily you have
a local infrastructure if your packages
on your computer there's a pack
library which can act as a data library
which means you can have a place where
you have a single copy of the data that
is shareable across projects you're not
going to fragment and have different
versions of the data across your machine
if it's available in a package so that's
great
you get to take advantage of the binary
format so they exist there for a reason
they're fast to load they're fast to
save they can handle lots of different
types of data structures and so that's
one reason to do it and then when you
build a package around data you can
facilitate the anticipated workflows
around that data you have Didier serving
you have assumptions and ideas of how
people are going to use it and you can
facilitate those things by building
functions in to have certain types of
graphing of that data or certain types
of processing of that data to help
people along and the linking of that
software and data you know makes that
analysis process easier if you can
anticipate what the analysis process is
and then you can use the documentation
system which is built right into your
analysis environment your your AR
console your our Studio server so you
can document that data right next to
where you're working with that data and
people can use it so you have all of
these advantages but there are a bunch
of different ways you can package data
in R into an R package that vary in the
degree of their trade-offs with these
best practices with for scientific
archival and for different types of
workflows and so I'm going to talk about
three and then kind of advocate for one
so first we have data in packages
themselves which is what I've been
talking about so far generally this is
going to be small data if you're
distributing through cran crane has a
five mega byte limit on the packages
themselves which means your bid are
going to be even smaller than that it's
generally going to be fixed these
systems are not designed for rapid
iteration of the packages on those on
those platforms and so you're not really
going to be having data that changes on
a really regular basis packaged up it's
usually going to be at the end of a
study you put it there you set it up and
that limitation is imposed by the
hosting services by these community
groups that are managing
crayon or another package distribution
like bioconductor like our own and our
open sigh and for that reason the
datasets really are limited so you
they're good for teachings datasets
they're good for demonstrations for your
packages but there's a lot you can't
distribute it through the normal rap the
data in the package directly next you
have data API wrappers and this is
becoming a very common pattern for
people to use across all sorts of
disciplines and all sorts of businesses
rather than putting your data in their
package you put your data online on a
server that can serve it via a web API
and then one builds a package around
those API is in order to pull them down
and so people can query that API
directly pull some subset of that data
or some query of that data and has some
great advantages the size can be
unlimited it's only limited by the
server infrastructure that's out there
which means you could have server
structures that involve many machines
across many databases in many places you
know you can have live changes those
servers are tied to other events other
web services things are changing minutes
a minute you can make that query
it'll differ a minute to minute I'm only
limited by your server capacity your
systems and white types of queries you
can send and what's built into the API
endpoints you design so that works well
for this sort of targeted querying for
asking a question of a big data set
where you can send that question up but
it's not as good for analyzing data and
mass because you have to move that data
every time you make a call and for a lot
of analyses maybe the query doesn't have
the ability to do that at the server
level or you have big computational
demands and if you're just trying to
distribute these data sets to a lot of
people you may not be able to manage a
server and have that infrastructure for
them that's computational nonetheless we
build a lot of data API wrappers at our
open side
biological ecological geological
chemical all sorts of scientific
databases exist out there and common
data repositories and we make a project
of
putting them with these of our via are
packages that wrap these api's you can
grab lots of things we work in labor and
economic data government social
government social data it's it's a whole
spectrum and this is just like a small
small screenshot of a very long webpage
that we have and this is sort of our
bread and butter nonetheless I think
what a pattern that we're using more and
that I like more and more is the idea of
data sync where we have a limitation of
local hard disk size which is often
adequate for a lot of the things that we
want to do so there's there are datasets
which we serve in a static fashion on a
remote source and they're all of the are
packages to sync that remote source to
your own computer and update it on some
kind of regular basis so you're not
working with live data minute to minute
changes but you can deal with version
changes across datasets as you have
regular releases on weekly or monthly or
annual basis and that's really limited
by your local analyst resources what can
fit on a hard disk but as long as you
have that you can analyze all of that
data at once and you're doing sort of
big global level analyses which is a lot
of what we do that's the limiting factor
and we want to be able to capture all of
the data together so I really like this
pattern it's in the like megabyte to
multi-gigabyte data scale now that
doesn't work for everything if you have
click data clicked it ends up in two
terabytes and petabytes and who knows
but in my case if a data point is not a
click but a person in a tie vex suit in
a forest all night catching a bat and
swabbing its anus with a q-tip and that
gets us one one data point when we get
some megabytes and gigabytes were really
doing well you know it works well for
this regular but not live updates and so
we can have version data which means
here's an analysis at version one in
that version two we have the speed and
versatility of having the data locally
when we work on it and we can facilitate
by wrapping this process in a package
that has functions and documents for
working for specific kinds of data so
how does a package like this work and
what tools do you use to build it well
the core that we've been using recently
is
package called datastore by a guy named
Richard it's John who's also part of the
our open side developers collective and
datastore is designed to manage this
data sync process between a remote and
local sources and dealing with
versioning so the thing you get with
datastore is the creation of a data
library in addition to having a package
library you have a data library and the
are up ters and store packages are what
enable us to do that and have it work
agnostically across different across
different operating systems sort of and
keep things efficiently stored if so we
keep the versions that we need and not
the versions but we don't it's able to
deal with essentially any file type
because you provide it with the load
functions you want for your data when
you're building a package it'll auto
generate the code for the core functions
you need in order to use the function to
use this package which is great it's
default setting is to use github or
leases as our versioning mechanism so
you attach data to github releases which
let you attach data of up to two data
files of up to two gigabytes size per
version but there's a potential for
other backends in the package so we're
working on making it connect with
scientific repositories like Xen odo or
figshare
or the open Open Science framework which
also enabled these sort of storage of
large versioned
objects the other thing we really like
to use is taking advantage of good file
types in order to speed up the iterative
data process so you can use you know the
sort of optimal archival CSVs and
Jason's and xml's but often because we
have this sync and load process when
people are working with the data we want
to make sure the data transfer is fast
and the loading process and fast so we
want fast losed formats and good
compression I really like FST for
tabular data there's a lot of good
options out there for fast on disk
tabular data and are at this point
between feathers and FF and all of these
things FST is a great one it works
really well in taking advantage of local
multi-threading and the thing that I
like a lot is it gets great compression
without a lot of loss of load or right
times and so you're able to you know
load multi-millionaire of data frames in
you know a matter of seconds it performs
at least as well as most of the options
out there and one of the nice things is
you can store data and work with it on
disk without loading to memory there's
an experiment spera mental package by
I'm getting it his name room Carol
Muller
to use a deep liar
pipeline with these files you have the
deep liar back-end just like it works
with an SQL database it can work with
FST files so an example of this so we
built a package for a society ascites is
the Convention on International trade of
endangered species we use this data a
great deal to understand the flow of
wildlife across the world
the organization has more than 40 years
of data of essentially every wildlife
trade between treaty countries that has
occurred but they didn't have a bulk way
to export it we needed to use it in bulk
so we built a package that that uses
these and we've just put up a first
version of it so we have our you know
version one of the data but it'll update
as we have new submissions decide ease
it updates on the order of months when
countries submit their trade data so
it's not a minute-to-minute thing but
its version and that's important for us
and essentially how it works is you just
have a date a function to call the data
which is site ease data if it's not
currently available in your library
it'll download that highly compressed
binary of the repository in this case
github and you can specify the version
you want to load so that'll load up it
moves relatively fast but once you have
done that a first-time 1.0 is cached on
your computer and so when you call it
again it'll load up immediately and so
we have quick access to in this case two
million rows of data that is easy to
work with across projects anyone can
just add this function in and you don't
have to have you know fragmentation of
the datasets across
different things are working with
sometimes you don't have control of the
upstream component of your data so what
we often do is have a data design
pattern where we have pulled from an API
but sync to a local database that we
maintain so there's an SQLite database
in our data library and for different
packages that in this case work with
taxonomic data or infectious disease
surveillance data we sync that data down
into local database you can work on it
and you just run sort of a single let's
download the current database function
it'll pull it down sync your look sync
what you have locally and you can work
with it then with the taxonomic database
we actually built originally an API
package to do the calls but because of
the slowness of that access we moved to
this design and so we actually have two
packages they have the exact same code
API so if in this case we're making a
call of in this case we're doing a
taxonomic lookup at the NCBI database
you know you can run it with an API call
it'll take a couple of seconds to pull
down the data make an HTTP request or
you can do it with the version of the
package that maintains a local database
and what we pull up is ten times faster
and actually scales much better too many
requests because you can vectorize the
requests locally but not to the API
other sort of helpers we use in packages
like this is giving a package status so
when you load up your package we show
the status of the local databases which
tables you have available what you've
downloaded when you've downloaded what
you can update and so this is helpful
it's especially helpful for our case
where the table availability depends on
one security permissions across the
shared project so maybe you'll have some
data and not others it shows what's
available when you load it up which is
helpful for an analyst one of the other
patterns we've been using across these
data access packages is in making
metadata useful so a lot of times when
there's a big data set available in a
public repository there'll be a code
book or a metadata sheet along
fit that has something like you know
descriptions of the codes that are there
the units that are available for the
columns the descriptions Nessa so
and it's often in a document like this a
PDF or a doc and it's there for good
reason because they expect people to
read it with their eyes they want people
to be able to scan it and look something
up but then you don't have the ability
to work with it in a computational way
for instance to link codes and
descriptions for visualizations so for
the case of CDs and some other projects
that we've worked on in this case we use
a package called tabular there wraps the
tabular PDF library which can extract
that data into a structured tidy data
frame and so every time we download this
PDF data it becomes tidy data so you can
work with that data
but then there's there a verse problem
this tidy data you know this data frame
you know contains a lot of values and
you want to be able to scan it quickly
to search it to use to use it for lookup
purposes and so we had this approach
where while we have the data itself
available within a package we also build
it into the help files as an HTML widget
so if you search for help about the
metadata of a package it will pop up an
HTML help file which has a searchable
data table you know a lot of people
don't realize that our help system is
capable of very rich HTML markup you can
have images you can have forms you can
have all sorts of things you'd have on a
web page you know it takes some rube
goldberg because you've got you know
HTML and JavaScript inside our
documentation files inside her oxygen
comments and there's a lot of escaping
and fixing you have to do but we
implemented inside ease I'm hoping to
wrap it into sort of a helper package
for this purpose too and then finally we
provide analysts with breadcrumbs so one
of the things we implement across things
is print functions that flag conditions
in the data
that might be important for instance if
there are field notes associated with
the fields and the subset you pull up we
show those flags so that people know
look at the notes or they or it might
show
there are duplicate fields in this data
and so that helps people as they're
exploring data but since it's only
involved in the interactive print
methods when you actually implement a
data pipeline you don't have the
performance hit of doing those lookups
and checks every time you print but it
helps people understand the data as they
get so in some if we're designing data
packages we have choices we can store
the data we can query the data or we can
sync the data and that choice really
depends on your data scale and your time
weight of your turnover
I think sync syncing version data is
something that is very useful and is
useful at the scale of data that a lot
of people work at it's helped with these
efficient formats like your feathers and
your FS T's and moving an SQLite
database back and forth and then when
you do that you can build rich
documentation and you can build
guideposts for your analysts along the
way
and all of these things help us sort of
minimize the trade-offs we have with
sort of archival storage problems and I
think as we develop a few more of these
tools we'll be able to connect with the
scientific backends with all of the
efficiencies that we get with these API
and syncing approaches so that's it
thank you very much
thank you
you